of all the enemy factions in the Legend
of Zelda one of the goofiest but also
most mysterious enemies there are is the
Yaga claim from breath of the wild it's
proven both in game and by external
means that these red tights wearing
ninja foes led by a very intimidating
rotund man indeed actually used to be
members of the sheikah clan and they
even expressed their disdain for their
former clan members by simply inverting
the original sheikah logo and claiming
that inverted logo as their own between
their methods culinary choice of food
and hideout location the most intriguing
piece of this clan is the leader who is
he
that round-bellied those tights that
black hair and that all true comical
spirits could their leader be none other
than the ferryman tingle himself I'm
kidding guys that's that's not tingle I
mean I guess maybe but that's not the
point of this video when you defeat
master Koh hingle he falls down a large
pit located in the very center of the
final room what an oddly specific
addition to their hideout am i right
don't worry this is what this quick
theory video is actually about so in the
first place we need to determine whether
or not we believe this giant seemingly
endless pit to be man-made or of natural
formation naturally forming pits most
commonly known as sinkholes are formed
over the course of many years of natural
erosion under the surface for instance
if there's a surface of the ground that
underneath is comprised of layered
limestone or other carbonate rock and
acidic rainwater or sea water is able to
seep into the ground over long periods
of time it will result in creating
openings under the ground of unknown
dimensions such as hidden caverns or
pits usually the ground at the top of
the sinkhole stays intact until it has
no support underneath it making the
reveal of the eroded space under the
surface much more dramatic man-made pits
are of course of any given depth and
width because we made them using tools
made by humanity that range from simple
to complex to carve out portions of the
earth we have as a species for millennia
known how to perform the essential
action of canoe
struction through deconstruction known
as digging a hole
so which process was used to create the
Yaga clan pit looking at the pit itself
we can immediately gather a couple clues
about its construction just beneath the
surface of the pit we can see that it is
decorated with lights and lovely frilly
drapes of the same iconic red Yaga clan
color and above that it's even had a
smooth stone surface of some sort
constructed along the edges no rails to
prevent people from falling in but I'll
get to that in just a sec now it is
possible that these decorations and even
the smooth stone surfaces were simply
placed here along this
naturally-occurring pit but I have a
couple of reasons why I personally don't
think this pit was of natural occurrence
firstly the hole itself is a bit too
even if you look at naturally occurring
sinkholes out in the wild or even within
urban environments you will rarely if
ever find one that is both perfectly
circular in its opening and retains that
same circular dimension all the way down
the entirety of the cylindrical cavity
but in-game for as far down the pit as
were allowed to see aside from a couple
understandable shifts in the stone wall
the pit for the most part retains its
shape all the way down huh secondly
these decorations here seem to me to be
of some sort of significance don't they
the drapes have markings on them that I
haven't been able to locate elsewhere in
the hideout and the lights are uniquely
different models from all the other
lights found nearby this coupled with
the smooth stone surface along the edges
and specific lack of any device that
would catch someone especially their
leader if they were to fall in seems to
me to be very deliberate if basically
everything about the pit itself seems
deliberate to me I took it one step
further though and discovered that link
can't actually climb the insides of the
pit now of course most people would
simply assume that that's just because
Nintendo themselves didn't want anybody
exploring within the pit and that under
normal circumstances the walls would be
climbing but then how do you explain
this the Gerudo sheikah tower is built
inside of a similar endless pit though
this one seems to be of natural
formations yet Lincoln climbed these
walls all the way down to the
very moment he's gone too far so why
isn't this the case with the Yaga pit
could it be that the man-made surface of
the walls inside the pit are too smooth
an argument could definitely be made
here since link is shown to be able to
climb other smooth man-made services
such as the walls of Gerudo town but can
he climb smooth sheikah surfaces which
is a perfect segue into the theorizing
section of this video now that we
understand the pit itself is most likely
of manmade origin the next logical
question is who made it was it the ego
first instincts are probably to say yes
yes it was the ego but there's another
clue we can gather that's actually from
the breath of the wild dlc you see
there's actually a shrine in this area
right here in fact and how does one get
this shrine to appear by throwing a
sheikah ball down the pit now logically
that should only mean one thing there's
more sheikah tech down there somewhere
that this ball had to come in contact
with in order to trip whatever switch
that makes this shrine emerge we also
know that sheekha technology was being
found from deep under the ground from
various cutscenes in this game and that
this nearby sheikah tower also emerges
from a similar bottomless pit meaning
underneath the surface seems to be
pretty clearly sheikah territory so was
it made by the sheikah probably but you
know who used to be sheikah yeah
the Yaga clan isn't it possible that if
the pit were of some important
significance the Yaga defectors who
previously knew about this pit or maybe
even helped make this pit chose the
specific area as their hideout for a
reason that reason being whatever that
pit leads to at the bottom of its
endless descent some theories like this
one I found on retro gaming magazine
that'll link to in the description
claimed that the pit was actually made
from calamity Ganon's resurrection or
summoning now let's tie in this theory
with the Ganondorf we see in the breath
of the wild two trailer since Ganondorf
is shown to be hidden away in an unknown
location somewhere deep underground and
the Yaga not only worship Ganon but are
known to be the ones attempting to
resurrect him what if the pit is
actually an entrance to ganondorf's
underground location
after all since calamity Ganon is made
out of malice and Ganondorf has shown to
exude said malice from his body isn't it
possible that calamity Ganon emerged
from the earth before heading to Hyrule
Castle and his point of emerging was
this Yaga pit what if the area Lincoln
Zelda are exploring in the breadth of
the wild sequel trailer is the bottom of
the well I mean the bottom of the pit
another theory is that well it's simply
a very elegant sheikah shrine puzzle and
this entire pit was dug so that link
could eventually throw a ball down it
this doesn't necessarily explain why the
Jager chose to have a hideout
surrounding this pit or why they adorned
it with various decor but it's a very
possible theory nonetheless but what do
you think what's the point of the pit is
it an entrance to Ganondorf nothing more
than a shrine puzzle or something else
entirely let me know in the comments hey
guys thank you so much for watching
please be sure to like this video to get
it spread around on YouTube for others
just like you and me and subscribe for
much more juicy Zelda content to come as
always a huge thank you to my patreon
supporters including my newest one
Maddie B you guys are amazing and a huge
inspiration to me to continue making
content if you're interested in getting
your name up here at the end of every
one of my videos follow the link in the
description below also down there you'll
find the link to my fabulous discord
server so please join up if you want to
chat it up with some cool tats indeed
hey that's all I've got for you so
without further ado this is master tuna
bandit signing out have a great rest of
your day
[Music]